okay this you have to see um in the
aftermath
of the last presidency some media
outlets have continued
to interview the children of the former
guy
really his two adult sons donald trump
jr and occasionally eric trump
eric trump is nowhere near as
um uh he's nowhere near as good as don
jr during these tv appearances
and he appeared on the greg kelly
newsmax show
and delivered a bizarre nearly
two-minute word
salad that truly rivals anything we've
heard from donald trump himself
apparently the apple really doesn't fall
far from the tree
and i challenge you to tell me what on
earth
is eric trump talking about the headline
at the bottom of the screen
presumably the topic of the interview is
what does joe biden do
in a day now without even seeing what
eric trump says
it's already funny because donald trump
played golf on something like the 18 or
19
of the days of his presidency he
essentially did no real work during the
last six to eight months of that
presidency
but somehow now the story is what
exactly is joe biden doing
put that aside watch this and i
challenge you
tell me what eric trump is even talking
about see if you can figure it out well
i mean in my whole life greg i've seen
it right i mean when i was uh when i was
a kid he called me six o'clock in the
morning honey are you up good you better
be up you know he'd call me at 11
o'clock at night
again testament i mean my father's just
a guy who's never stopped his entire
life has been
like that whether it's in business uh no
matter what he sets his you know mind to
um you know the apprentice etc etc the
presidency the way he campaigned i mean
there's never been a person in political
history that's campaigned as hard as my
father has and frankly as hard as our
our family did and you know when you saw
biden i was talking about obviously you
know by not leaving his basement in
wilmington delaware right there but
you know you see these farmers i go all
over the country you'd be with coal
miners you'd be with farmers you'd be
with you know first responders
um you know cops just great americans
that own small businesses
etc right you know these people are up
at five o'clock in the morning
and they don't come back sometimes until
midnight you know from work and
sometimes they're working two and three
jobs and
you know you're the president of the
united states i mean you should set an
example and the one thing that no one
could ever say about my father as
as as crazy as the media was
right there's no person in the media as
much hatred as there often was for my
father who wouldn't say that he was the
hardest working president this country
has ever had and
okay so before we get to what i'm sure
is just a riveting and compelling
story from eric trump i guess first eric
trump is talking about how hard his dad
worked when he was president
and then he's talking about how hard
some farmers work
and it's all meant to make joe biden
look bad
is that the gist of this even the hosts
starting to look look a little bit
confused
let's now listen to eric trump's
anecdote
and i'm sure it's just endlessly
inspirational and greg just a kind of
funny little anecdote i remember you
know so many different people from new
york times etc they'd be following him
rally at a rally at a rally
these are 25 year olds they would be
sleeping in a backpack
you know in in the back of an auditorium
after the sixth rally with three red
bulls three empty red bulls next to them
totally passed out
they couldn't keep up with him yet you
know he's delivering
hours and hours of speeches to different
crowds where he has to keep
such mojo such energy going the entire
time such passion going
i mean he would literally run these
young kids who were following him around
the press pool he would run them into
the ground and uh
you know that's what this country needs
and uh you know you look at around the
world at the world leaders
you know do we think putin has energy do
we think um you know
go down the list i mean these guys have
you know men and women have tremendous
work ethic
it's funny how the first guy he thinks
of to praise
for his energy is vladimir putin like
down to every detail this is just
hilarious and there's a certain
disconnect from reality where eric trump
says listen for
all the things that were said about my
dad
no one could say that he didn't work
hard and and the opposite is true
trump golfed a historic amount more than
any other president trump had endless
so-called executive time on his schedule
which just means
kind of hanging around watching tv hours
and hours every single day
trump often wouldn't come down to the
oval office to even ostensibly start
working until 10 11
noon even trump stopped even pretending
to do work
for the final six to eight months of his
presidency
and towards the end of that they weren't
even publishing a schedule they were
simply putting out
every day a note that said the president
will work
from early in the morning until late in
the evening he will have many phone
calls and many meetings like they
weren't even pretending
to claim that donald trump was working
towards the end
it's the opposite of what eric trump
says was true about donald trump's
work ethic now one other thing eric's
big example
of trump's hard work is trump did lots
of rallies
this actually relates to something
significant
doing rallies isn't work it's not being
the president and in fact
donald trump was so obsessed with
getting back to rallies even during the
pandemic
that it was part of the reason he wasn't
doing any real work during the last half
year
of his presidency but that's what they
all see
as doing work and as being busy and
there's just a fundamental
misunderstanding
a lack of understanding as to what it is
a president should or could even
uh be doing and uh then pray you know
praising putin at the end
is just sort of the cherry on top i
don't know why eric keeps doing
interviews don
jr says disastrous crazy and dishonest
things
but he's better on tv eric just seems
confused and half of what he says is
completely unintelligible